a dramatic event this morning on the
streets of khartoum in sudan it appears
that the
country's head of state leading sudanese
general abdul fatter al-burhan has
dissolved that country's hybrid civilian
military government essentially taken
power himself or taken power in the name
of the sudanese military we're hearing
that at least five civilian cabinet
ministers have been arrested the home of
the country's prime minister civilian
called abdullah hamduk has been
surrounded a number of other national
and regional officials have been
arrested the art the airport shut the
internet's down phone signals mobile and
landline
phone now unusable and we have seen
pictures on social media of civilians
coming out burning tires protesting on
the streets of the capital as well so
very unstable at tensions between
civilian groups the civilian government
as well and the military have been
building really since the uh long-time
authoritarian leader in that country
omar al-bashir was deposed in 2019 the
two groups a big civilian coalition they
hammered out an agreement with the
military to run
the country it was a democratic civilian
cabinet a civilian a sovereign council
as well run by the military that seems
to have really fallen apart now
they were supposed to be leading up to
democratic elections in 2023 that
doesn't look like it's going to happen
the economy i think chiefly uh behind
this uh inflation fuel shortages food
shortages all sorts of problems with the
economy this broad civilian coalition
that have been going for democracy in
that country they've been
experiencing real problems in that
country some of the groups members of
that coalition have been moving towards
the military and i think what we've seen
is the military particularly the
president
sudanese general taking advantage of
that and essentially claiming power for
himself this morning but we'll have to
see what happens